When it comes to action movies, Underworld is the
gothic horror franchise that can't seem to rest
in peace. But if more sequels are on the way,
the series' leading lady won't be coming along.
Let's take a look at why Kate Beckinsale
won't be back for more Underworld.
As it crashed into cinemas at the tail
end of 2003's summer movie season,
"Underworld" vividly re-imagined
what vampire fiction could be
by positioning its blood-sucking beasts square
in the middle of a full-blown action epic.
In the process, it made a legit action superstar
out of actress Kate Beckinsale. Perhaps more
surprisingly, "Underworld" launched the vampires
vs. werewolves franchise the cinematic world never
knew it needed, and essentially put low-budget
genre studio Screen Gems on the Hollywood map.
To date, Screen Gems and their partners
at Lakeshore Entertainment have produced
three sequels and one prequel
for their flagship franchise,
and Kate Beckinsale has appeared as "Death
Dealer" Selene in every single one of them.
The most recent "Underworld"
flick, subtitled "Blood Wars,"
hit theaters in 2016, and wasn't particularly
well received by either critics or audiences.
That sort of performance rarely means
great things for a movie series, and to
further complicate the "Underworld" producers'
potential dreams of Selene's future adventures,
it appears that Beckinsale has joined the
ranks of people who don't want anything
to do with the franchise. In a 2018
Variety interview, the actress gave
some candid remarks about certain roles she'd
passed or, it turns out, had left behind.
When asked about the possibility of making
another "Underworld" movie, she was blunt.
"I wouldn't return. I've done plenty of those."
Even by Hollywood standards,
that curt response doesn't leave much
wiggle room for future appearances.
"I have seen so much war. So
much killing. I can't bear more."
If you're among the few "Underworld" fans
who actually bought a ticket and experienced
"Blood Wars" in theaters, you probably aren't too
heartbroken over Beckinsale's outright dismissal.
After all, "Blood Wars" really was a bit of a
mess, and its less than enthusiastic reviews are
enough to give an impression that the franchise
itself might feel a bit long in the fang.
While Beckinsale didn't really address why she's
ready to move on from "Underworld" for good,
it's a reasonably safe bet that she's grown
as weary of the franchise's neo-gothic
escapades as critics and viewers seem
to have. That's hardly a surprise,
given that the actor was never really
the blockbuster franchise sort.
It's easy to forget, but Beckinsale actually
came up in showbiz on the strength of her work
in smaller-scaled projects like "Much Ado About
Nothing," "The Golden Bowl," and "Laurel Canyon."
In the years since her "Underworld" breakout,
Beckinsale has continued to dip her toe in the
indie cinema pool every once in a while,
balancing these projects with larger-scale
fare like "Click." For instance, Beckinsale's 2016
reunion with her "The Last Days of Disco" director
Whit Stillman for the tragically underrated period
piece, "Love & Friendship," earned rave reviews
... and came out the same year as "Underworld:
Blood Wars." Which career path would you choose?
"Oh, I can't decide!"
Per a 2017 interview with Yahoo, while addressing
the rumors of her playing Wonder Woman,
Beckinsale acknowledged that part of why she
passed on the role was out of a desire not
to appear in Princess Diana's famously
short-skirted outfit and embarrass her
daughter. In her statement, Beckinsale clearly
addressed her "Underworld" getup, as well.
"I don't know if I was desperate
to be in a leotard. I'd already
done the rubber trousers. You
have to take in that you have
a child at some point and how much
could you possibly embarrass them."
It would seem, then, that Kate Beckinsale wasn't
too keen on those "rubber trousers" throughout her
"Underworld" tenure. Whether or not the thought
of squeezing back into that skin-tight ensemble
another time fueled Beckinsale's decision to
leave the franchise for good remains a mystery,
but it sounds like the pants may
have factored into the process.
Whatever the reason behind Beckinsale's
decision to leave the "Underworld" franchise is,
one thing is certain: It definitely isn't
because she's feeling too old for action roles.
In a 2020 interview with Women's Health, the then
46-year-old actress discussed her healthy diet,
her action star-worthy fitness regime and her
2021 Amazon Prime Video action movie, "Jolt."
"'It can feel like a little bit of a political act
to be a woman over 32 who's having any fun at all.
And by that, I don't mean doing drugs and
drinking and partying, because I never am,
but being goofy, and going out
[...] it somehow seems to be risqué,
which is just ridiculous to me. And I witness
men constantly doing whatever they like,
whether that's in relationships, or deciding
to buy a motorbike, or getting a tattoo."
Perhaps not entirely coincidentally,
"Jolt" turns this concept on its head.
Beckinsale plays Lindy, a former bouncer
with violent impulse control issues.
"I explain, 'It's this woman who's
got this rage disorder.' And every
single woman has said, 'Oh. Me.' Women
are really f------- angry right now."
Kate Beckinsale's recent and upcoming
filmography makes her star-making role as Selene
seem like the odd one out in her résumé. The
actress seems to be building on the critical
success of "Love & Friendship," and focusing on
projects like the coming-of-age drama "Farming,"
and the Amazon Prime Original
mystery drama "The Widow."
According to Deadline, one of
Beckinsale's more interesting
upcoming projects is director Catherine
Hardwicke's "Prisoner's Daughter," which
will be about generational family trauma and
the long road to healing. In other words,
it's going to be about as far from
vampire action movies as you can get.
Perhaps this is the ultimate reason Beckinsale
won't return for "Underworld 6:" She simply wants
to star in projects like these instead. Beckinsale
clearly has much to give on the acting front,
and let's face it — five movies of stunts in
a skin-tight costume is plenty for anyone.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.